la pluie verglaçante
on est encore loin de tout comprendre
sur les conditions qui mène à sa
formation c'est pourquoi un groupe de
chercheurs américains et canadiens ont
réalisé un projet de recherche sur le
terrain pour mieux décrire et comprendre
ce phénomène métérologique
le mercure a chuté le verglas commencer
les vents forts se sont levés a vraiment
des conditions difficiles il faut
s'attendre à voir le pire de cette
cuivre glaçante grésil ce soir hier la
neige par endroits mais ça va changer
rapidement puis vernir sont par la suite
se soigne la pluie et par la suite
demain soir et dans la nuit suivante oui
il ya six jours où la météo si tout et
n'importe quoi
on ne sait plus trop ce qui va nous
tomber dessus et ce n'est pas
nécessairement la faute des
prévisionnistes
[Musique]
joue le thériault est professeur et
titulaire d'une chaire de recherche du
canada elle étudie les phénomènes météo
hivernaux extrêmes les raisins plaques
verglaçantes sont formés dans les mêmes
conditions atmosphériques ce qui rend la
prévision un peu compliqué mais c'est
vraiment important de le mentionner
quand il ya un risque de pluie
verglaçante parce que l'impact est
différente neige neige mouillée pluies
verglaçantes brésil tout se jouant truc
temps dans la colonne d'air on veut
comprendre dans quelles conditions la
plus agaçante va se transformer en
grésil puis pour ça il faut aller
prendre évasion sur le tard et leur
laboratoire c'est la vallée du
saint-laurent et celle du lac champlain
un des endroits où les précipitations
mixtes sont les plus fréquentes
justin mines du pilote ce projet de
recherche
américano-canadien le projet winflo mix
est unique en son genre autant par son
ampleur que les outils déployés sur le
terrain ce qu'on ne comprend pas encore
bien ce sont les processus qui se
produisent à plus petite échelle comment
le relief environnant par exemple les
montagnes et les vallées influence le
mouvement des couches d'air au sol et
commence à une incidence sur le type de
précipitations
c'est quelque chose qui nous intéresse
beaucoup
pendant deux mois et demi durant l'hiver
2022 ils ont traqué les tempêtes
qui veut vraiment
pour comprendre comment la neige se
transforme dans sa chute ils vont
scruter chaque tempête simultanément
avec des radars au sol qui balaie la
précipitation des stations météo pour
capter les conditions ambiantes des
caméras photo pour des clichés de la
précipitation au sol des ballons sont
pour mesurer la température dans la
colonne d'air et un avion pour
caractériser ce qui se trouve dans nuage
ça nous permet de balayer l'atmosphère
avec nos instruments et de voir comment
la précipitation se transforme en
fonction de sa hauteur de sa distance et
des vents on a une vue détaillée sur ce
qui se passe
ok
ce soir-là près d'acton vale on se
prépare à un épisode de pluies
verglaçantes
pourtant au sol il fait moins huit
degrés celsius mais à deux kilomètres en
altitude la neige fond il fait 5 degrés
le radar capte la réflexion de la
précipitation la bande rouge c'est de la
neige fondante et de l'eau de lucchi
même en se refroidissant au contact de
l'air froid juste en dessous va rester
liquide
une chose fascinante qui se produit dans
l'atmosphère c'est la présence d'eau
super froide
ce sont des gouttes d'eau plus froide
que le point de congélation
toujours les keys
en laboratoire à l'uqam on en a fait
l'expérience
on a déposé une goutte d'eau sur une
plaque refroidissant
même sous zéro la goutte reste de
l'équipe elle va geler à moins 12 degrés
celsius
c'est tout super froide va
instantanément se transformer en glace d
un impact au sol que ce soit une branche
un fils ou un pare brise
or durant sa chute les gouttes 12 super
froid de risque aussi de croiser des
poussières atmosphériques ou des
cristaux de glace qui peuvent la
transformer en grésil avant d'atteindre
le sol souvent dans les modèles peints
en schématise plus les grosses
particules par c'est ce qui est
important pour les prévisions de la
météo pillon on minimise peut-être
l'impact des particules plus petites
comme ces petits cristaux de glace là
parce qu'ils produisent pas beaucoup la
curation à la surface ce qui rend aussi
les prévisions complexe si que toutes
ses formes de précipitations peuvent
coexister dans le même nuage
chacune ayant son propre comportement
en fonction de sa taille de son poids
ces vitesses
sur le tarmac de l'aéroport d'ottawa on
se prépare à son disque qui se passe là
où dans les nuages
l'avion du centre national de recherches
du canada est bardée d'équipements de
mesure et un moss on échantillonne tout
le nuage
dans ce cas ci on essaie de voler à
l'intérieur du nuage tout est dans sa
partie supérieure
le plan de vol décrit une série de
passages qui traverse la précipitation
de long en large et de haut en bas
souvent un mélange de neige de grésil et
de pluie
l'appareil nous fournit un niveau de
détail ou une résolution bien plus
grande que ce que peuvent fournir les
instruments au sol on veut décrire les
différentes couches d'air leur
température le type de particules dans
le nuage
leur mélange et les zones de transition
de solides et liquides c'est une sorte
de vision en 3d du nuages et des
précipitations avant qu'elle n'atteigne
le sol
sold in si toutes les données que l'on
récolte dans les nuages nous permettent
de valider le type de précipitations en
altitude est ce vraiment une
précipitation solide est ce différent de
ce qu'on voit au sol quelle est la
température quel est le portrait 3d
réelle des vents chauds
le vent on l'oublié du rand
précipitation il peut tout bousculer
dans la colonne d'air de l'atmosphère
jusqu'au sol catcheur friedrich est une
spécialiste de l'analyse des images
radar elle peut voir ces vents changent
de direction à 180° en altitude
jusqu'à ce type de changements de
direction peuvent créer des zones de
convection à l'endroit où les gens se
rencontrent
nn wahdat mines cela peut forcer l'air à
monter et transformer la précipitation
les mouvements peuvent déplacer par
exemple des précipitations d'une couche
froides à chaudes verticalement ou
transporter une couche de précipitations
d'une région à l'autre horizontalement
c'est sans compter aussi sur la
topographie du sol qui affecte les
corridors devant
la vallée du saint laurent est orienté
non en reste donc il ya des vents froids
qui restent dans les basses couches qui
est canalisée par la vallée du
saint-laurent pilote eut on a des vents
chauds et humides du sud qui arrivent
les clans ne les conditions favorables
pour avoir la plus verglacée
avec les hivers compris team plus doux
quel impact cela aura sur la nature des
précipitations hivernales
il peut cependant y avoir des subtilités
des surprises par exemple des
changements sur la fréquence des
tempêtes trajectoire ou encore sur le
profil des vents
en améliorant notre compréhension du
fonctionnement des tempêtes on obtient
des informations qui nous permet
d'ajuster les modèles climatiques sur
lesquels on se base afin de mieux
comprendre les changements futurs et
sans doute faire en sorte que les radars
voit encore mieux venir ce qui vous
tombera dessus
[Musique]